not John you and how that's an
interesting working relationship because
I know I'm looking
get out you were the co-writer as well
as the star and you really in many ways
coached hell over a period of many years
through that picture
what was that adventure like well first
of all let me thank you for doing this
for how and see this this wonderful
talent assembled here and Bob Boyle is
out there is going to be a hundred years
old one of our geniuses and film design
and it just it's wonderful for me to see
the young folks he'd he'd have loved it
all I must tell you that he'd really
have been very comfortable here tonight
at that time how was like the guy to
work with we all were drawn to him for a
lot of different reasons but he had a
special aura around him and of course he
was this genius fellow genius director
and all of this stuff but his way was so
magical and one of the things I said
recently about him I said it was like I
must it must be something like the guys
who work the athletes at work with Phil
Jackson he's smart as hell he he knows
each player completely he gives them
absolute freedom to play the game and
with how it was like he'd set up set up
an atmosphere very nurturing atmosphere
made you feel like it was your set if
even if you came in for 15 minutes
that's the way you felt and then he
would just in just the subtlest of ways
create this very loving atmosphere and
fun he would never say anything that
wasn't a little bit of a joke and in
that way he got the wonderful
performances
you